hi I'm chase hi I'm really pumpkin
hi I'm Maddie and you're watching
BuzzFeed you guys swim the full year and
now your lives are completely different
what does it feel like how was the
massive fan reaction to the show it's
weird because like this whole quarantine
thing is hard because one you're locked
down so you see like the social numbers
changing which is awesome because it
sort of validates that the show doesn't
in soccer well thank you thank you guys
it's like a weird thing because we
haven't really had any outside like
connection besides you know these little
things like I said it kind of doesn't
feel real yet anytime I go to the
grocery store now it's getting it's
getting more and more real but I think
I'm really loving I think we're all just
really excited to like do what we did
last year again with so what you guys
doing every time I thought maybe the bar
is here it's here now raising the bar
did you guys keep anything from the set
I think the only thing that I kept my
bracelet you kept your poster yeah I
didn't get to keep any money I'm gonna
honor that I decided that JJ would have
on the first day I got casted as guys
like he would have a Zippo lighter so I
got to keep it was just like chillin
who's John B's not the tiniest person
ever so I was like hey sue me my good
friend here from episode 9 his name his
name is codec whack yes he's my puck I
have I've done a little thing to him
since then I drew all
I have bandanas - I've like three or
four miles my tab it during the
quarantine how does it feel to get
easily recognized in a bandana chase
it's the hair it's weird it's weird
what's a rope oh you auditions before
they people might be surprised to find
out about I read through sensible
characters foolish - I say that was
something something that maybe people
don't know is that I read for actually
rave read for judge a first actually
rave Joffe packaging
there's a bunch of like stuff that
should probably pretty well-known that I
Edition for I got pretty close on Jamal
all in my block auditioned for everybody
says I look like him I have one good one
I don't I don't know if I've told you
guys this but when they did the Han Solo
reboot I got pretty deep in the casting
to play Han Solo see it oh nice dude
that's awesome
I think I read like five times for that
and then they casted
thirty-four-year-old Coen Brothers flex
yeah oh just true great what was the
first impression of each other okay
everybody everybody was great like I I
was so stoked because we met and then we
did the table read and then we all hung
out after that we went to that dinner
and I know it's like wow you've been
pretty rad this is gonna be a really fun
summer remember I didn't like Boston at
first that's the only yeah and now I
love we all went to the movies one time
then like the movie just ended an
awesome sorry I gotta go use the
bathroom so we're like sitting there
waiting for Austin and chase dead
serious looks at us and like should we
leave him we were like no I was like
that stopper and like at that point I
was just like I'm going full method like
I don't like this guy yeah what was the
toughest stunt you had to film for the
show I like the fight scene with Barry
yeah yeah I think the hardest stunt
might have been the stuff on the boat
with Ward we went all out and we're just
beating the piss out of each other for
three days and I feel like the most
dangerous stunts in the ones that aren't
planned because sometimes we'll just
like decide to do with them like the
tire really jumps through a car window
yeah
you make the cut though yeah I'm good
how early in the season to do you think
the pose we'll find out with John B and
Sarah are still alive and what do you
think the reunion will people I think
it's gonna be pretty early that's right
they're obviously gonna get into some
sort of trouble in the Bahamas they're
there for a reason but that's a great
question I don't know I would think like
- so zoom because the show is called
outer banks right Oh can't be in the
Bahamas for forever and I do think that
the reunion will be a beautiful thing on
social media you might still be how did
that happen we were recording together
for a bit like when the show came out
because we didn't want to be alone when
the show premiered so we spent about a
month together in a one-bedroom
apartment
so naturally we'd just a little much so
we've all kind of gone our separate ways
we're no longer important team together
obviously everyone is about the love
triangle between Kiara JJ and Pope what
can you tease about the possibility of
JJ and Kiara being together and how will
that impact hope and Jada's relationship
no I don't know this was written already
it's the love triangle that nobody knew
was gonna happen but I'm so glad it did
because it's pretty great why does
everybody insist on being the weirdest
people on camera when I'm done like the
reason there is no Pokemon poking was to
avoid a situation that might happen in
the near future so we see what's it to
opened up like why in the first place we
implemented that rule and that rule mean
for all I cause like maybe it's like oh
this is why no pillar of makng nobody
should be we started we started the show
with this like fantastic rule of like
friendship and then ideally bro we're
all like yeah yeah immediately like well
obviously I think we all work so well
together it's friends if it's not hard
to picture any of us like being a
relationship it's gonna be a key ever
are gonna be written to end up together
at all it's definitely gonna have to
take time because that is just like such
a
- transition between hope and key and I
think that will gradually get there and
it will show this like Jamie said that
the rule of no poke on poke macking is
there for a reason I mean that or it's
like look like maybe this show will be
the first show - she'll be like you can
be in a different place in several
relationships and make it work you know
you never know like if you look at it
from where Pope and key ended I think it
was really cool that there's so many
different layers of seeing all of them
like actually care about each other
maybe it was a spur-of-the-moment thing
and maybe it was like emotions were so
high and you felt so bad about the fact
that like both was absolutely losing his
mind that this was something that felt
right in the moment and I think it's a
teenager like so many times you've all
gone through you kind of look at a thing
that you've done and you're like yeah
that was just kind of a moment thing and
I think it's calm to kind of leave it on
that note to where you're not sure and
she's really supposed to be with and
there's different layers to partnership
so I think it'll be interesting to see
like when Pope is not you know
self-destructing is he person that he
would want to be with you know what I
mean or either of them like we don't
know where he could end up like who
knows who he meets in season two or
season three like or I think everybody
was going through so much at the end of
the season let the girl live like
everything you talk about Chiara it's
always like whether or not she should be
with Pope urge a day when she like
herself is a good character yeah like
like we shouldn't like be every time you
bring up Chiara should be she should be
with jay-z it should be like well let's
like accept key for the person that she
is yar and Sarah good characters in
their own right like that's totally
normal
hooyah for Bailey who do you think here
should be with I feel like a third party
should come in you know the reason why
Chiara was the one who's so adamant
about like pugs don't mass on toes like
y'all are the only friends she has she
can't lose you guys I think a third
party would be the best way to handle
that like somebody else seems to come in
I also think it would be interesting to
see key bring somebody else into the
Pogues
guys spy games is what
which episode is that again for was such
a fun episode to watch Jason Madeleine
can you share any of your fun stories or
memories from filming it
Maddy was super sick that's not really a
fun memory to be honest everybody was at
Country Club and because they were
shooting that Chase and I weren't on set
so we came to set and tried to get in
the backgrounds like we asked for
possible to put us in some clothes that
weren't ours some moments on the show
included some improvisation like JJ's
speech about his dad in the hot tub are
there any other moments from the show
like that yes oh yes be safe was
completely a problem say I see that the
internet really liked when I called
topper sweetheart JD and Rudy literally
turn their show is like that in real
life times like 100 and so sometimes
when you're like on like in between
shots and you're trying to be kind of
like goose down you know or you know in
a bad mood and then you got rien eighty
over here like trying to decide like if
if a taco or hamburger would win it
seemed like there was some kind of
history or past between rates and Chiara
well season to get into that will be
learned more about Chiara spookier I
think yeah because you were at my house
I was just like saying yeah I did know
rape from being at your house constantly
I don't know I have no idea that's a new
revolution flashback I think you didn't
like rape just from like you know when
Sara and Chiara we're friends because
there's no way you were that we were
ever like cool will we get more of
chiaroscuro I hope so you know
what's it like beating up and getting
the beat on people like juice Starkey
awesome people in real life I don't like
everybody like rehearsing stones
together it's like some of the fun yeah
it's like learning a dance except you
get to look cool and Drew's really
awesome he's like he's like a great
great guy so he so don't hate on him in
real life he's not he's not really the
main plot line for season 1 was hunting
for treasure what do you think season 2
will focus on getting the treasure back
it seemed like that FBI guy believes
there at the end and now the cops have
heard john be accused warned of killing
his dad would go down in season two I
feel like he should for sure gonna be
this close to getting caught and then
he's gonna get straight you know you
know yeah or or bigger than any
cliffhanger on our show yeah I was like
if what would apply it what do you mean